dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly fajir in the last few
years the pace of progress in machine
learning research has been staggering
neural network based learning algorithms
are now able to look at an image and
describe what's seen in this image or
even better the other way around
generating images from a written
description you see here a set of
results from began a state-of-the-art
image generation technique and marvel at
the fact that all of these images are
indeed synthetic the GAM part of this
technique abbreviates the term
generative adversarial network
this means a pair of neural networks
that battle each other over time to
master a task for instance to generate
realistic looking images when given a
theme these detailed images are great
but what about generating video with the
dual video discriminator again
DVD gain in short deep Minds naming game
is still as strong as ever it is now
possible to create longer and higher
resolution videos than was previously
possible the exact numbers are 256 by
256 in terms of resolution and 48 frames
which is about 2 seconds it also learned
the concept of changes in the camera
view zooming in on an object and
understands that if someone draws
something with a pen the ink has to
remain on the paper and changed the dual
discriminator part of the name reveals
one of the key ideas of the paper in a
classical again we have a discriminator
network that looks at the images of the
generator network and critiques them as
a result the discriminator learns to
tell fake and real images apart better
but at the same time provides ample
feedback for the generator neural
network so it can come up with better
images in this work we have not one but
two discriminators one is called the
spatial discriminator that looks at just
one image and assesses how good it is
structurally while the second temporal
discriminator critiques the quality of
movement in these videos this additional
information provides better teaching for
the generator which
in return be able to generate better
videos for us the paper contains all the
details that you could possibly want to
learn about this algorithm in fact let
me give you two that I found to be
particularly interesting one it does not
get any additional information about
where the foreground and the background
is and is able to leverage the learning
capacity of these neural networks to
learn these concepts by itself and two
it does not generate the video frame by
frame sequentially but it creates the
entire video in one go that's wild
now 256 by 256 is not a particularly
high video resolution but if you have
been watching this series for a while
you are probably already saying that two
more papers down the line and we may be
watching HD videos that are also longer
than we have the patience to watch and
all this through the power of machine
learning research for now let's applaud
deepmind for this amazing paper and I
can't wait to have a look at more
results and see some follow-up works on
it what a time to be alive thanks for
watching and for your generous support
and I'll see you next time